the innovations that have been driven by
market funded by the basically the US
taxpayer everything in the iPhone comes
out no that's that is completely
nonsense so that is complet there are a
few specific patents that can be linked
back to some specific touch screens
lithium batteries
[Music]
microprocessors I'm conscious of the
fact that when we talk about
Marxism uh and capitalism we can very
quickly get into caricatured perspective
with regards to these terms I'd really
love for each of you to lay out um in a
few words what is your vision of these
terms what do they mean and what do they
look like not just theoretically but in
practice Matthew sure well thank you
very much for the opportunity to to be
here today and and be part of this
debate I'm looking forward to it very
much I mean I suppose at a premise I see
capitalism or market system as a model
based upon the idea of free exchange of
uh people being able to make decisions
about their own lives and then through
the the market and the decisions they
make uh freely deciding our economic
course um it's a highly decentralized
system uh it's a system that I think has
proven extremely successful uh over
human history I mean I I basically um
accept that for most of human history
life was pretty much nasty British and
short as as Thomas Hobbs famously said
and what capitalism has lived US is an
immense level of prosperity over the
last 200 years we've gone from over 90%
of people in extreme poverty down to 10%
um where we've seen life expectancy
double we've seen global inequality has
even declined um and quite frankly over
the last 30 years we've even seen
amazing progress as we've seen
liberalizations in more countries um
looking at moves towards markets in
China or India or or in all over East
Asia um I think what we're going to end
up in this trap in this debate is uh
there's there's always this potential I
think and and Aon uh sometimes false
pray and I guess sometimes so do I but
you can have this idea of this Ideal
World and you say well capitalism hasn't
delivered us everything we want out of
out of society but I think you actually
have to you know and I'm willing to take
on uh to some extent the the criticisms
of capitalism and all all the Ws it has
and say I think that's better than any
other system that's ever been tried in
human history and generally speaking
when social systems have been tried it
has resulted in huge amounts of poverty
destitution and and uh enslavement of um
and I think that's something you can
just dismiss and say well that's not
what Marxism wanted you know of Marxism
did not want the Berlin wall or gags or
anything like that but I think that a
system which has failed every time in
practice is probably one that fails in
theory as well and there are fundamental
systematic reasons why Marxism never
actually works in practice and that's
because it pushes against um much of the
way we should want to operate society
and and therefore inevitably fails and
if we're going be pers Ed here in this
debate that Marxism is a better system
you have to tell me why it's not going
to end up in the same miserable
situation it has every single other time
it has been tried why will this time be
different how will we organize Society
who will Who will allocate the means of
production what jobs will I be able to
do what happens if I if I do want a
voluntary exchange and I want to work
for somebody as an employee as an
employee you're not going to let me do
that what if I want to buy a product at
a certain price you're going to stop me
from doing that what what is it actually
going to mean how are you going to solve
what is effectively the the the um the
problem that H highlighted here which is
the knowledge problem who's going to
choose how to allocate resources in what
way so I think I might leave my my
opening thoughts there and look forward
to discussion Aaron um over to you and
tell us about your vision uh Marxism as
you see it and as you define it well
firstly I I love I love the example of
China because of course every failure of
China is because of the Chinese
Communist party and the failures of
State socialism but every success taking
00 people out of economic deprivation
now having a longer life expectancy than
the United States by the way cuber does
as well those are nothing to do with
State intervention or non-market
policies just it's a thing to dwell on
isn't it all the upside well that's
markets all the downside that's that's
nothing to do with us goov in terms of
Marxism I I I would sort of add some
caveats to what was said previously so I
think Marxism is a is a world viw and
it's an interpretation of how market
economics works and you can be a
currency Trader and be a Marxist I mean
I know some of them um so I I I I
wouldn't say that just because somebody
claims to be Marxist they have an
attachment to defending a set of regimes
here in the 21st century I think it goes
far more deeply than that when Marx
wrote Capital the full title of that
book was capital A critique of political
economy he was criticizing the liberal
political economy of the manchest the
school English econ economists generally
not just English economists but
generally speaking of Ricardo Smith
jevans and he said
actually we'll go back to the start of
this conversation utopian Vision Marxism
no far from it he was critiquing what he
viewed as a utopian Vision that was the
whole point of capital it was a critique
of these ideas which were increasingly
hegemonic sorry there's not a better
word I can probably use right now uh
which were increasingly hegemonic
amongst the British ring class European
ruling classes which effectively went
around the world so how does Marxism
help us I would say it helps us in at
least in at least two areas firstly it
helps us understand Economic Development
far more
astutely why does something happen why
are certain Commodities made why do does
the global economy look the way it does
I think there are well I'll be honest I
think there's no other better
explanation actually than effectively
Marxist
perspectives all of what we're looking
around here is embedded within a
metaphysics everything from this pen to
my shoes to these trousers they were all
made for exchange value for profit they
wouldn't have been made without it and
the beauty of Marxism is it helps you to
break down some of the contradictions in
social life to better understand what
that means right so for you I presume
history unfolds because some powerful
people do stuff some great men achieve
some great things and uh it's it's just
quite happen stance going to the second
point about the uses of Marxism from
economics to history we actually know we
can look at things like demographics we
can look at things like technological
change geopolitics and we can have a
materialist conception of history and in
the 21st century as much as people like
to you know dish it out on KL marks and
Marxist pretty much everybody agrees
that actually history unfolds as a
result of material circumstances when he
writes the German ideology in the mid
19th century that's quite a bold
statement okay so in a way we are all
marxists now when it comes to history uh
I won't go on to his contribution to
literary Theory arguably just as big I'm
not Terry Eagleton uh but to stick to
the first point I made about economics
he is the first to really understand
that these crises you see in capitalism
aren't accidental and they're not one
offs and by the way in the mid- 19th
century people weren't so sure they
thought and by the way the liberal
political economists thought well we've
had an economic crash here but that's
because of these particular reasons
those particular reasons Mark says no
because of inbuilt contradictions within
capitalism which maybe even Matthew
agrees with I mean again we're all
Marxist now in so much as we know there
are crises attendant within capitalism
they happen regularly they are
inevitable that wasn't something that
was generally agreed on the mid 19th
century so again he's built a consensus
there we don't really talk about um
Marxism for me provides the best
framework by which to understand why
decisions are made by by people
operating within a capitalist framework
and why they can can fail uh and so for
me as a Marxist I look at for instance
the global financial crisis 20078 you
have declining rates of profitability
from industrial Capital there's less
profit being made by capitalists in
countries like Westman Germany the
United States right across Western
Europe so of course you're a capitalist
you want High rates of profit what do
you do you go into Financial speculation
you go into real estate you go into
reinsurance much higher margins much
higher rate of return but of course too
much Capital goes into these sectors we
have massively over financialized
housing markets in the US and across
Europe and the whole thing collapsed in
20078 now if you're a Marxist you see
that coming and that's why Marxism is
very useful and if you're a Marxist by
the way you can see what's coming over
the next five 10 15 years which is again
declining rates of profit declining
rates of growth particularly in East
Asia what does that generally mean if
you're a historical materialist well as
a Marxist you look back at the early
20th century the Great War Between the
European powers and you can understand
how declining profit and increased
economic competition between great
Powers with really important senses of
national identity can spill over into
real bloody warfare that's a blind spot
for people like Matthew it's not for
marxists so that's why I like being a
Marxist very proud l so uh in the medium
term I I'd call myself a luxury
communist because my book is about where
our species goes over the next two three
400 years I believe that what we're
seeing with automation right now is just
as big a shift as the Industrial
Revolution the consequences will be
enormous we can't begin to understand
them in a 100 years time that's why I
call myself a luxury communist because I
think we'll see the end of that division
between labor and capital Leisure and
work in the meantime in the here and now
I'm just a Social Democrat I'm very
bored
I'm a Marxist radical Social Democrat
which by the way is more in line with
how most people think about public
services energy housing work taxing the
rich then what Matthew's saying so I
think it's time we stop painting
marxists as these dangerous radicals and
put us where we belong the voice of
common sense I mean Marxism claimed to
be a scientific theory and in those
terms we also do have to critique it
because it said um capitalism would
inevitably come to the end its own
contradictions uh would would destroy
itself this would happen in the most
developed place
now of as a scienic theism has been an
and total failure there hasn't this
great rise up of people who said down
with the system in terms of is everyone
a materialist now historian I mean I
studied history I I I didn't think
everyone was a materialist historian
might be some historians in the room who
disagree there's there's obviously lots
of different theories about history I
mean i' I've no doubt that there is some
value in you know reading marks you know
you should read your classical thinkers
but in terms of as a political system or
in terms of a historical Theory I think
it's
failure uh in every conceivable way and
and shouldn't be something you should be
proud of um in whatsoever just in out of
interest um in terms of the models that
you both Advocate what countries would
you identify as kind of being the best
representations of those models look
yeah I don't think there's any country
that I wouldn't largely criticize for
loads of different reasons and it's it's
many flaws but I think the the're
generally free market countries that
have been quite successful in terms of
Market relations you can look at uh up
and recently somewhere like Hong Kong
you could look at Australia New Zealand
the UK the US have all been some of the
the richest countries as well as Western
European increasingly some Eastern
European countries in terms of actually
existing economic regimes which I agree
with and I think are very positive this
is going to sound cliche from somebody
on the left Scandinavia Finland is the
happiest country on Earth um they have
markets I'm not suggesting otherwise by
the way there are markets in my book too
I it's called fully automated L
communism I that's a contradiction it's
talked about in there there are markets
in there too there have been experiments
in you know socializing Finance markets
and how that can help expedite worker
ownership for instance so the idea that
necessarily socialis socialism and
markets are two completely different
things isn't necessarily accurate in
fact the left tradition before Marx was
was they were called ricardian socialist
it's quite a strange thing to think now
you have people like David Ricardo
inspiring socialist but they they did
exist so Market socialism is a thing and
I'm not particularly averse to markets
where you Embrace markets about it's
about who has access to to credit and
capital right and and so who who gets
the money to invest in the businesses
and why and under what conditions um
under the conditions we have wealthy
asset owners get Capital to buy more
assets so that we can pay them more
rents so they can expand workers can't
get access to Capital and you see this a
beautiful example of this by the way is
in the UK housing market until very
recently if you wanted to get property
the easiest easiest way to get property
is to buy property and to get more
property now Matthew can say well there
are some disincentives bolet mortgages
aren't aren't as generous as regular
mortgages you need more credit for a
deposit that's all true but once you
have that Revenue stream those rents
coming in you can expand your property
portfolio meanwhile home ownership in
this country is falling it's been it's
it's well below where it was in 20078
and I do find this kind of presumption
that the world's getting better we're so
happy markets are working well life
expectancy stagnating or falling in the
United States over the last several
years of course CO's a huge part of that
uh but if you look at this country home
ownership life expectancy debt all going
in the wrong direction self-reported
happiness you know I agree it's a very
sort of it could be quite flaky and and
too
relativistic but it's quite clear to me
that countries going in the right
direction Finland Sweden I think with
the exception of their immigration
policy Denmark but quite obvious to me
so I I'm I'm quite pragmatic as a as a
Marxist I think they are nullifying the
worst excesses of market capitalism and
again going back to Marks that's what
the book was called seek of political
economy and finally sorry he had a great
line which kind of undermines what
Matthew is saying I'm not here to write
recipes for the cook shops of the future
which is a great shame but this idea
that marks was this propositional
thinker telling people to go around
murdering others inaccurate now you can
say many people have suffered in his
name absolutely correct but none of that
is anywhere in any of his books which
you should read if you take the example
of of housing which is just come up here
now I do not think under anyone's
imagination that there is a free market
or anything like a free market housing
in this country there is the Town and
Country planning act that overwhelmingly
restricts the building of housing the
UK's built houses much slower than any
other country uh around not any other
country but most other major countries
around Europe um that we've got a huge
strong relation on the housing Supply
because of a a regulatory intervention
and that is at the cause of so many
economic and social issues including you
could argue the increase inequality um
put together low interest rates of um
increase the value of people's Capital
assets again that's a market uh
intervention now I think overall the
story when it comes to capitalism
inequality is is something that people
completely misre um in in so many
different ways in the first instance the
truth is that global inequality if you
do a genie coefficient between
individuals has actually declined uh in
the last 300 years and that's because
the it's not just like 1% of people who
live in palaces now um can have access
to luxuries but more or less the great
power of capitalism is bringing luxuries
to everyone if you just compare um to
1998 which is the scheme of things not
really that long ago um just 10% % of
British households had an internet
connection 27% had a phone and 33% had a
computer those are now up to 89 95 and
88% respectively you've got a system
which using the profit incentive rewards
people for Innovation rewards people for
creating things and profit is the reward
you get for um creating a good whose
Parts is equal uh come you've made
together is equal more than the cost of
it made to produce so I think that the
the profit motive in the market system
has delivered these these innovations
that have made things like an iPhone in
my pocket with extraord
um technological capacity accessible to
the masses this is actually where I get
confused by aon's whole
philosophy because he talks about luxury
communism but in fact everything that he
seems to love has come out of a
capitalistic system it's come out of the
innovations that have been driven by a
market system funded by the basically
the US taxpayer everything in the iPhone
comes out that is completely nonsense so
that is completely there a few specific
patents that can be linked back to
some touch screens lithium batteries
microprocessor we are not going to make
this about the iPhone so so um you can
pick yourself afterward by all means um
I do want to give Aaron a chance to come
back on this all the things you're
talking about inequality falling well
actually for the first 40 50 years of
the Industrial Revolution living
standards don't increase even though we
do have an extraordinary increase in
productivity and and Innovation
absolutely they only start to increase
when you get worker organizing
Collective action people asking for more
money and I find it incredible that
basically your argument is well we got
rid of child slavery laws we got the day
we got we got the weekend we've got
socialized Healthcare and it's all
thanks to the bosses I mean nobody
thinks that not even the bosses think
that so all the progress yes there's
been a great deal of progress that's
been created by markets technology
ination absolutely of course there has I
like markets I like technological
innovation much of it by the way funded
by the US tax pay throwing to but at the
same time those those those contractions
in inequality and those improvements in
in in living standards for all of us are
because people fought for them to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas